what about
just the simple
and for people who don't know one of the
things that irobot has created is the
roomba
uh vacuum cleaner
what about the simple robot
that that is the room bus quote unquote
simple
that's deployed in
tens of millions of in tens of millions
of homes
what do you think about that
well i make the joke that i started out
life as a
pure mathematician and turned into a
vacuum cleaner salesman so
if you're going to be an entrepreneur be
ready for that
be ready to do anything um but i was you
know
i
there was a there was a
wacky uh lawsuit that i got posed for uh
not too many years ago
and i was the only one who had emailed
from the 1990s
and
no one in the company had it so i went
and went through my email and and it
reminded me of
you know the the joy of what we were
doing
and and what was i doing what was i
doing at the time we were building
um
building
uh the roomba
one of the things was we had this
incredible incredibly tight budget
because we wanted to to put it on the
shelves at
there was another home cleaning robot at
the time it was the uh
electrolux
uh
trilobite
which sold for 2000 euros
and to us that was not going to be a
consumer product
so we
had reason to believe that 200 was a was
a thing that people would buy at
that was our aim but that meant we had
you know that's that's
on the shelf making profit
that means the cost of goods has to be
minimal
so i find all these emails of me
going you know i'd be in
taipei for a mit meeting and i'd stay a
few extra days and go down to shinshu
and talk to these little tiny companies
lots of little tiny companies outside of
uh tsmc taiwan semiconductor
taiwan semiconductor manufacturing
corporation which
let all these little companies be
fabulous they didn't have to have their
own fab so they could innovate
and then um
they were building their innovations
were built stripped down 6802s
1682 was what was in an apple one get
rid of half the silicon and still have
it be viable
and i'd i'd previously got
some of those for some earlier failed
products of a robot and uh and that was
um in hong kong
going to all these um
companies that built
you know
they weren't gaming in the current sense
there were these handheld games that you
would play
or
or birthday cards because we had about a
50 cent budget for computation
so i'm trekking from place to place
looking at their chips
looking at what they'd removed
their interrupt their interrupt handling
is too weak for a general purpose so i
was going deep technical detail and then
i found this one from a company called
winbond which had and i'd forgotten it
had this much ram it had 512 bytes of
ram and it was in our budget and it had
all the capabilities we needed yes so
you're excited yeah and i i was reading
all these i was calling my family
so did you think did you ever think that
you guys could be so successful
like eventually this company would be so
successful did you could you possibly
have imagined
um no we never did think that we had 14
failed business models up to 2002 and
then we had two winners the same year um
uh
no and then you know
we i remember the board
because by this time we had some
venture capital in
the board went along with us building um
some robots for you know aiming at the
christmas 2002
market and
we went three times over what they
authorized and built 70 000 of them and
sold them all
in that first because we released on
september 18th
and uh they were all sold by christmas
so it was uh
so we were gutsy but
but yeah you didn't think this will take
over the world well this is uh
so a lot of amazing robotics companies
have gone under over the past few
decades
why do you think it's so damn hard
to uh run a successful well there's a
robotics company there's a few things
um one is
expectations of capabilities by the
founders that are
off base
the founders not the consumer and the
founders the expectations what what can
be delivered sure
mispricing
and
what a customer thinks is a valid price
is not rational
necessarily yeah
and expectations of customers
and
just the
sheer hardness of getting people
to adopt a new technology and i've
suffered from all three of these
you know i've had
more failures and successes
in terms of companies i've suffered from
all three
so
do you think
one day there will be a robotics company
and by robotics company i mean where
your primary source of income is
from robots
that will be a trillion plus dollar
company
and if so what comp what would that
company do
i can't you know because i'm still
starting robot companies yeah
i'm not making any such predictions in
my own mind i'm not thinking about a
trillion dollar company and by the way i
don't think you know in the 90s anyone
was thinking that apple would ever be a
trillion-dollar company so these are
these are very hard to
predict but sorry to interrupt but don't
you because i kind of have a vision
in this in a small way and it's a big
vision in a small way that
i see that there would be robots in the
home
at scale like roomba but more
and that's trillion dollar
right and i and i think there's a
there's a real market pool for them
because of the um um demographic
inversion you know who's who's going to
do all the stuff for the older people um
there's too many i'm you know i'm i'm
leading here
it's going to be too many of us
and
um
but
we don't have capable enough robots to
to make that economic argument at this
point
do i expect that that will happen yes i
expect it will happen but i gotta tell
you we introduced the roomba in 2002 and
i stayed another
nine years we were always trying to find
what the next home robot would be and
still today
the primary product of 20 years almost
20 years later 19 years later the
primary product is still the roomba so
irobot hasn't found the next one do you
think it's possible for one person in
the garage to build it versus like
google
launching google self-driving car that
turns into waymo you think it's pos
this is almost like what it takes to
build a successful robotics company do
you think it's possible to go from the
ground up or is it just too much capital
investment
yeah so
it's very hard to get there
um
without a lot of capital and we're
starting to see
you know uh fair chunks of capital uh
for some robotics companies um you know
series b's because i just saw one
yesterday for 80 million dollars i think
it was for co-variant
[Music]
but it can take real money to
to get into these things and you may
fail along the way i've certainly failed
at rethink robotics um and we've all
lost 150 million dollars in capital
there so okay so rethink robotics is is
another amazing robotics company you
co-founded
so what was the vision there
what was
the dream and
what what are you most proud of with
rethink robotics i'm most proud of the
fact that we got um
robots out of the cage in factories that
was safe absolutely safe for people and
robots to be next to each other so these
are robotic arms robotics arms they're
able to pick up stuff and interact with
humans yeah and that humans could retask
them uh without writing code right and
and now that's sort of become an
expectation for a lot of other little
companies and big companies are
advertising they're doing that's both an
interface problem and also a safety
problem yeah
yeah
so i'm most proud of that
i completely i let
myself be talked out of
what i wanted to do
and you know you've always got you know
i can't replay the tape you know i can't
replay it maybe
maybe i you know if i'd been stronger um
and i remember the day i remember the
exact meeting
um can you take me through that meeting
yeah
um
so i'd say that i'd set as a target for
the company that we were going to build
three thousand dollar robots with force
feedback
um that was safe for people to be around
wow that was my goal and we built uh so
we started in 2008
and we had prototypes built of plastic
plastic gearboxes
another three thousand dollar you know
uh
or three thousand dollar
i was
saying we're going to go after not the
people who already have robot arms in
factories the people who never have a
robot harm we're going to go after a
different market so we don't have to
meet their
expectations um
and and so we're going to build it out
of plastic it doesn't have to have a 35
000 lifetime it's going to be so cheap
that it's opex not capex
and so we had we had a prototype that
worked reasonably well
but
the control engineers were complaining
about these plastic gearboxes with a
beautiful little planetary gearbox um
but
we could
use something called serious elastic
actuators we embedded them in there we
could measure forces we knew when we hit
something et cetera
the control engineers were saying yeah
but this this is torque ripple because
these plastic gears they're not great
gears and there's this ripple and trying
to do force control around this ripple
was so hard
and i'm not going to name names but i
remember one of the mechanical engineers
saying we'll just build a metal gear box
with spur gears
and it'll take six weeks we'll be done
problem solved
two years later we got to get the spur
gearbox working yeah um we
cost reduced it every possible way we
could um yeah but
now the price went up to and then the
ceo at the time said well we have to
have two arms not one arm
so our first robot product baxter now
costs 25 000
and the only people who are going to
look at that were people who had arms in
factories because that was somewhat
cheaper for two arms than arms and
factories
but they were used to um 0.1 millimeter
reproduce a reproducibility of motion
and certain velocities
and we i kept thinking but that's not
what we're giving you you don't need
position repeatability use force control
like a human does no
no but we want we want that
repeatability we want that repeatability
yes all the other robots have that
repeatability why don't you have that
repeatability so
you clarify force controls you can grab
the arm and you can move it or you can
move it around but but suppose you um
can you see that yes suppose you want to
yes
suppose this this thing is a you know
precise thing that's going to fit here
in this right angle
under position control you send your you
you have fixtured where this is you know
where this is precisely and you just
move it open you know and it goes there
if force control you would do something
like
slidell over here till we feel that and
slide it in there and that's how a human
gets precision yeah they use force
feedback yes and get the things to mate
rather than just
go straight to it yeah
couldn't convince
couldn't convince our customers who were
in factories and were used to thinking
about things a certain way
and they wanted one wonder so then we
said okay we're going to build an arm
that gives you that
so now we ended up building a 35 000
robot with one arm with um
oh what are they called um
um
a certain sort of gearbox made by a
company whose name i can't remember
right now but it's the name of the
gearbox um
and um but it's it's got torque ripple
in it
so now there was an extra two years of
solving the problem of doing the force
with the torque ripple so we had to do
the
the thing we had avoided
and
for the plastic gearboxes we ended up
having to do the robot was now
overpriced and
um
and that was your intuition from the
very beginning kind of that this is not
you're opening a door to to solve a lot
of problems that you're you're
eventually going to have to solve this
problem anyway yeah and also i was
aiming at a low price to go into a
different market price that that didn't
have a thousand dollars would be amazing
yeah i think we could have done it for
five um but
you know you talked about setting the
goal a little too far for the engineers
exactly
so why would you say that company um
not failed but went under
we had buyers and um
there's this thing called the committee
on foreign investment in the us cyphus
and um that had previously been invoked
twice
around where the government could stop
uh foreign money coming into a u.s
company
based on
um
defense requirements
we went through due diligence multiple
times we were going to get acquired
but every consortium had chinese money
in it
and all the bankers would say at the
last minute you know
this isn't going to get past cyphus
and the investors would go away
and then we had two buyers once we were
about to run out of money two buyers
and one used heavy-handed legal stuff
with the other one
said they were going to take it
and pay more
dropped out when we were out of cash and
then bought the assets
at 1 30th of the price they had offered
a week before
it was a tough week
do you um does it hurt to think about
like an amazing company that didn't
you know like i robot didn't find a way
yeah it was tough um i said i was never
going to start another company i was
pleased that everyone liked what we did
so much that the teams
the
team was hired by um
three companies within a week everyone
had a job in one of these three
companies some stayed in their same
desks because the com another company
came in and rented the space
so i felt good about people not being
out on the street
so baxter has a screen with a face
what
that's a revolutionary idea for a uh
robot manipulation like for a robotic
arm
how much proposition did you get well
first the screen was also used during um
codeless programming where you taught by
demonstration that showed you what its
understanding of the task was
so it had two roles
um
some customers hated it
and so we made it so that when the robot
was running it could be showing graphs
of what was happening and not sure the
eyes other
and other
people and some of them surprised me who
they were saying well this one doesn't
look as human as the old one we like the
human looking yeah so there was a mixed
bag
but you think that's
uh i don't know i i'm kind of
disappointed whenever i talk to um
to roboticists
like the best robotics people in the
world they seem to not want to do the
eyes type of thing like they seem to see
it as a machine
as opposed to a machine that can also
have a human connection
i'm not sure what to do with that it
seems like a lost opportunity i think
the trillion dollar company
will have to do the human connection
very well no matter what it does yeah i
agree
you